I very much love your new show last man
on earth and one of the things I love
about it is there's so many funny ideas
your character has and he's this typical
guy not super motivated just how he
solves problems and he's not he's not
the greatest guy in the world no no when
it comes to solving problems so one of
the problems is that in when when you
are the last man on earth there's no
running water there's nobody running
those basic utilities yeah and your
character comes up with this horrible
way to create a toilet and you're look
at it and you're like actually I bet a
lot of us guys would do that it's that
you know what I mean it's there's an
element that makes sense I mean why
don't you tell people what it is
well after trying a variety of things my
character just cuts a hole in a diving
board and creates a toilet pool yeah and
he just sits over the hole and goes to
the bathroom in this pool and just lets
it build up you need to find the right
diving board so you tweeted out a
picture of you this is you and the
production guys I guess trying out is
this gonna work
those are the two guys that we made the
show with that who did the lego movie
and 21 22 Jump Street yeah they're very
funny guys and now how hurts on diving
board pooping yeah but then you also
tweeted out something else or retweeted
something where you say you got the
inspiration from a major celebrity who
was that well some but if somebody
tweeted to me a picture of Rihanna on a
diving board and
I it was this was let me let me tell you
again this was a retweet this was not a
yourself ownership over that yeah okay
you know like okay well you know I I
don't I'm not gonna say yea or nay to
this I'm just gonna spread along and and
you know what the word gets out there
yeah strange man
you